let's talk about this first big story
i love this headline from axios it's
just three words biden threatens putin
wow that's that's amazing i say you know
video journalism has come
yeah yeah well hey i mean that's a good
thing it's better than some
sensationalist 20 word title uh we'll
keep it simple in a video call that
lasted for just over two hours on
tuesday biden warned russian president
putin that if russia invades ukraine the
u.s will impose unprecedented sanctions
and provide additional weaponry to the
ukrainians national security adviser
jake sullivan said now axios doesn't
want to go as far as to say u.s troop
deployment because sullivan kind of
danced around it saying he doesn't want
to say we're bracing for you know
rotation of boots on the ground because
we already have rotational deployments
in the baltics but he is saying that is
entirely a possibility the us getting
involved in a ground war in ukraine
sounds like a bad idea
sounds like a terrible idea particularly
on the 80th anniversary of pearl harbor
right so i think this is once again um
this is
the eu
has been pressing this fight forever
right they're the ones that talked about
the expansion of getting the ukraine in
this is where uh the the more radical
members of the eu and nato talked about
making ukraine a member of nato right
this has been pushing and pushing and
pushing forever
biden's also doing this for political
expediency he needs a wag the dog moment
the wall street journals polling came
out today
absolutely horrific right he's i think
it's 26 percent right track wrong track
26 20 26 26
right track uh what 62 63 wrong track
you've got uh among uh people who think
he's doing great versus uh
terrible it's 37 to six these are
unprecedent unprecedented low numbers
not just not just on kamala harris on
him he has lost the country
okay and now he has no political capital
to support this orgia spending that's
going to bury everybody up on capitol
hill so he needs he needs to change the
conversation here's how he's going to
change the conversation he's going to be
a tough guy right he's going to push
around putin so he's going to try to use
this
to uh
purely for politics to try to get his
ratings up is his to show he's a leader
and this is a disaster and i got to tell
you it's not just it's not biden it's
the uniparty the worst comment of the
day was not from the pencil neck jake
sullivan right should they should be
focused on the chinese communist party
and what's happening in taiwan in the
south china sea with the center the
worst comment was from the senator from
mississippi uh wicker
who said everything's on the table
including combat troops not just the 200
advisers they have in there now combat
troops and tactical nuclear weapons a
nuclear strike i mean this guy's just
he's just it's he's blowing hot air come
on he's not blowing i'm not listen he's
a he's a very respected member he's a
very respected member particularly he's
on the armed services committee this guy
was on neil cavuta this is not this is
not a lightweight look he's in the
united states senator you have guys in
the united states senate say combat
troops and uh and and tactical nuclear
weapons are not a nuclear strike is not
off the table and you brought up a very
important point because historically
when the popularity of leaders goes down
you know history says that those leaders
start wars and conflicts and if there
was a conflict between
the united states and russia china would
of course take advantage of that
situation invade taiwan immediately and
geopolitically this is one of the worst
situations that the united states could
make because we should be working with
russia aligning with them and and and
establishing a better relationship
because there is a lot of tension
between russia and china but with us
going full force against russia it's
absolutely idiotic
this was trump's plan this is the
reverse kissinger nixon in 72.
look you have the you have the eurasian
land mass okay
and right now american foreign policy
since 1914 has been we will never allow
one power or a series of power to
control central asia the eurasian
landmass the world island right because
he who controls the world island can can
control the world so and we and so and
think about it in 19 on december 7th
of 1941 you had you had
germany uh italy the empire japan they
just broke up russia was a part of that
that just you know just come apart with
the attack today you have china pakistan
iran
okay turkey
and with north korea north korea and
russia and we have forced those guys
into the into the chinese camp you talk
about internal politics putin needs this
too for his internal popularity and she
needs this you have three leaders all
for political reasons let's let's do the
mullahs in too yeah but steve i would
push back a little bit because during
the trump presidency trump sent lethal
weapons to ukraine something that even
obama was scared of doing and i when you
look at his uh you know foreign policy
it was pretty much on par especially
when it came to bombing syria because
when we look at syria when we look at
yemen these are the proxy wars that are
happening between russia and the united
states and there might be another one in
ukraine ukraine might be the only guy in
the national security council that
fought
to not to not launch the uh the cruise
missiles into syria president trump did
not want to do that at the last minute
that was kind of an accommodation to the
uniparty but wasn't it ivanka trump who
also said that she was crying and then
it was trump's son who said it was her
that convinced them to bomb syria wasn't
that i don't i don't want to say that
but people were putting in front of him
you know about the children being uh the
chemical attacks with gas which we found
out later was not true it was not true
at all and and his remember nobody's put
more pressure on putin than trump had
okay but you're right they i i think and
that was his um not acquiescing but i
think trying to work with the national
security apparatus
but he but but exactly you know morning
joe these guys david ignatius the next
day oh he's acting like a president
brian williams these missiles are
amazing and beautiful and yeah they
called them presidential and they loved
them they adored him this is what
mcmasters was about now of course
biden's not any better biden called
putin a killer recently and then a
couple days later he literally bombed a
u.s aid worker and killed seven children
after that so baden i think is even
worse but i think there's a coherent uh
foreign policy that has been steady
against russia uh throughout the last
few presidents
my youth i was you know on a uh on a
destroyer hunting soviet submarines in
the south china sea but it's so nobody's
more anti
uh anti uh soviet anti-communist and the
russians are run by kgb guys they're bad
guys that being said they should be an
ally
not an enemy we have a problem with
china right now trying to consolidate
the eurasian land mass and china is
coming at us on silicon valley west in
taiwan south china sea and against our
ally
india in the northwest frontier and
biden's done such a bad job with our
great ally india the front of the
financial times today is
wait for it putin and modi sitting there
hugging right cutting a deal because but
this is what president trump had nobody
could have been closer yeah that's our
central ally against
against china right with japan and here
you got this thing is in total disarray
okay the american people have voted
about biden right now first off you can
tell 81 million people didn't vote for
him these polls mathematically couldn't
be this this low but these are
unprecedented numbers
in the 20s first of all if you get in
the 30s on the right track
but he but the polls have swung i mean
it started he's he started off this
collapses that collapses too much it's
just afghanistan was the start of the
collapse though
right so around around i think that i
think that was a trick i think that was
a triggering mechanic i think it was
getting i think it was bad up until the
vet covered people i don't know which
way he was going i do want to keep us
focused on uh on the foreign policy
stuff but i do want to say i think what
happens is like i said before uh last
time you were here trump was
anti-elected the the atlantic story stay
alive joe biden i think people voted for
joe biden because they didn't care and
didn't they they were convinced anything
was better than trump and they were
deceived and now they're realizing just
how awful of a mistake they made in
electing this guy and you see around
afghanistan when they're like he gave up
our air base but but i don't want to
rehash all that stuff i want to talk
about but you can see it in the ukraine
we're going to make the same mistakes
first off when you have people remember
wicker had been briefed
okay he just didn't walk into that
interview cold he had been briefed
they've had discussions and he said
nothing should be off the table that
means they're actively discussing
combat troops deployments to the ukraine
and they want to keep on the table his
words not ours
tactical a nuclear strike but here's
what i want to mention you talking about
china it was i think pompeo who said
that china has infiltrated the u.s at
every level every level every level
we've seen numerous what prof how many
professors have been arrested for
basically giving away our research to
china double dipping china's paying them
the u.s is paying them then they're
giving our research away i think mapeia
was right and so i'm i'm concerned about
when when when i read the story about
michael flynn and i think what you're
talking to sally yates is that what
happened and he said i think russia is
not a big threat i think china is the
bigger threat then she panics she's like
oh no sounds to me like they are
colluding with china we know that don
junior and biden fly on air force two to
go to that private equity deal and now
you're wondering why
i'm sorry sorry not don junior hunter
yeah all right where's hunter i deeply
apologize there's hunter
hunter
slip of the tongue hunter biden and his
dad flying the plane to to china air
force two air force
an official in an official capacity
don't get mad at me that was a mistake
no no but but in all seriousness uh
first of all four trillion dollars
you're for your audience understand
something your pension funds your
pension four trillion dollars of
american capital have gone into china to
finance it through larry fincher this is
the collusion
of
of wall street and global corporations
you know the nba players called them out
the other day you had today apple
announced a what a 400 into 275 billion
joint venture in china to help their
technological prowess have they invested
275 billion dollars in the heartland of
this country to increase the
technological prowess of the united
states and the workers in the united
states no this is a company protected on
american soil and they're active partner
of the chinese communist party look to
make the system work does not conspiracy
make the system work you have to have
the slave labor of china the slave labor
of china and the state-owned industries
okay keep wages down throughout the
world that's why wall street and the
party of davos finance it yep that's how
they make the profits and they want to
make china the rest of the world and it
was the henry kissinger david
rockefeller policy that in the 70s
instituted all of this and literally
have set it up for the global world they
want china to be the rest of the world
social credit score surveillance states
smart cities smart grids all of that
it's first being implemented in china
and it's going to be implemented in the
united states and now we're going to get
bogged down remember
let's put in perspective china is the
great the chinese communist party is the
greatest enemy we've ever had the
largest economy the most sophisticated
right that one with the deepest culture
what 5 000 years 10 000 years
russia
is this economy is the size of new york
state okay it's the size of new york
state and it's imploding it's a
demographic death spiral they don't make
any technology we want they got great
hackers and you know what they got they
got natural gas that the germans and
others want right the gdp of italy so
exactly exactly
and yet we're going to put you have a
u.s senator a republican and this is one
thing i want to say is a populist and a
nationalist this is the type of neocon
this is the type of neocon ism that has
destroyed the republican party and
helped to destroy this country that you
know this nine trillion dollars we spent
in iraq and afghanistan over 20 years in
what the 10 000 or 12 000 combat
casualties or the the killed in actions
plus the 40 or 50 000 casualties is
because that thinking wicker's thinking
today oh everything's on the table boots
on the ground combat troops and a
nuclear strike thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm now don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you